My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the Clean Sight application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey.
我叫 Diakalola Amujam。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业，也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的人。Marion 博士的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中给予了我极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这对我来说非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些已获得资格和正在接受培训的临床心理学家的经历。书中的各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都各不相同，这为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。
I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. What if the thing stopping you from progressing your psychology career isn't your age, isn't your degree and it isn't your grade. But the story you're telling yourself about what's possible. Every week I receive messages like, I'm an older applicant and I don't have a psychology degree, is it too late for me? Or I've got a two to and I haven't studied for a while. Have I ruined my chances? Today I'm rejoined by a brilliant previous guest, 47-year-old Claire Dunn, who is a trainee
我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。如果阻碍你心理学职业发展的不是你的年龄、学位或成绩，而是你对自己“什么才是可能的”所讲述的故事呢？每周我都会收到这样的信息：“我是一名大龄申请者，没有心理学学位，现在还来得及吗？”或者“我的成绩是二等二学位，而且我已经很久没学习了，我还有机会吗？”今天，我再次邀请到了一位出色的前嘉宾，47 岁的 Claire Dunn，她目前是一名实习
clinical psychologist. and we are creating a roadmap for two older applicants. This isn't a fantasy you can do anything type conversation. It's a grounded and honest look at what retraining in psychology really involves, practically, emotionally and strategically. I hope you find it so useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined once again here today by the brilliant Claire Dunn, who is,
临床心理学家。我们正在为大龄申请者制定一份路线图。这并不是那种“你可以做任何事”的幻想式对话，而是一次脚踏实地、坦诚的探讨，深入分析了在心理学领域重新培训在实践、情感和战略层面上的真实含义。希望这对你有所帮助，如果你喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本期播客。我是临床心理学家 Marianne Trent 博士，今天再次邀请到了出色的 Claire Dunn，她
is now officially a trainee clinical psychologist. Hi Claire. Hi, Marion. Thanks for having me back. Thanks for coming back. And to be honest, we've never really been out of each other's WhatsApp and LinkedIn since we met, have we? No, absolutely not.
现在正式成为了一名实习临床心理学家。你好，Claire。你好，Marion。谢谢你再次邀请我。谢谢你回来。说实话，自从我们见面以来，我们从未断过 WhatsApp 和 LinkedIn 的联系，对吧？是的，绝对没有。
It's been, yeah, it's been great. I've been picking your brains, haven't I? Right my course. Well, I just like you, Claire. And sometimes my podcast gets get to keep me as a little buddy after we meet and I think you're one of those people. So we spoke before for our first episode about you having got onto training
这真的很棒。我一直在向你请教，对吧？关于我的课程。嗯，我就是喜欢你，Claire。有时我的播客嘉宾在见面后会成为我的小伙伴，我觉得你就是其中之一。所以我们之前在第一集里谈到了你如何在 47 岁时进入培训
at the age of 47. So if people wanted to watch that first or afterwards then that would be a great place to start. But we thought it would be really helpful to kind of have a look at a couple of different vignettes really for if somebody is like, I think I want to be, in this instance, a clinical psychologist we're gonna talk about. But obviously lots of the things we're going to talk about might be, you know, comparable for other branches of psychology.
阶段。如果人们想先看那一集或者之后再看，那将是一个很好的起点。但我们认为，针对如果有人像——在这种情况下，我们谈论的是临床心理学家——那样的情况，提供几个不同的案例分析会非常有帮助。当然，我们谈论的很多事情可能也适用于心理学的其他分支。
But we're going to have a look at a couple of vignettes for if we were working with somebody in a team and they were like, you know, I'd always, I've always loved to, you know, the idea of what you do. Yeah. But I think it's too late, you know, or maybe I do want to do it, but I don't know where to begin. So we're kind of going down that road. And we're going to kind of have a little bit of a, yeah, a little bit of a look at what we would advise. So other options are available, other opinions are available, but you know, you and I are both pretty crafty at JobCrafting, which is an episode I did with Jack. It was a brilliant episode as well. So if people are like, what is JobCrafting? Have a look at that one.
但我们将看几个案例，比如如果我们在团队中与某人共事，他们说：“你知道吗，我一直很喜欢你所做的事情。”但我觉得太晚了，或者也许我想做，但我不知道从哪里开始。所以我们正沿着这条路走。我们将探讨一下我们会给出什么建议。当然还有其他选择和观点，但你知道，你和我都很擅长“工作重塑”（JobCrafting），这是我之前和 Jack 做过的一期节目。那也是非常精彩的一集。所以如果人们问什么是“工作重塑”，可以去看看那一集。
Okay, so with no further ado, let me read this first vignette to you and to our audience. Give me one moment. Okay, so we've got Sarah, who is 40 and works as a secondary school English teacher. She's been teaching for 15 years and is currently ahead of year. She has two children aged 7 and 10. She returned to full-time work after maternity leave, but has found the role increasingly emotionally draining. She's always been invested in psychology and mental health
好了，废话不多说，让我为你和我们的听众读一下第一个案例。请稍等片刻。好的，我们有 Sarah，她 40 岁，是一名中学英语老师。她教书 15 年了，目前是年级主任。她有两个孩子，分别是 7 岁和 10 岁。她在产假后回到了全职工作岗位，但发现这份工作越来越让人情绪耗竭。她一直对心理学和心理健康很感兴趣，
and is often the member of staff that pupils gravitate towards when they're struggling. She's completed safeguarding training, pastoral care work and regularly liaises with CAMS, social care and educational psychologists as part of her role. She achieved a 2-1 in her undergraduate degree, was English literature, but has no formal psychology degree. She's got a few concerns. She feels too old to retrain and worries about starting again at the bottom. She's anxious about finances and balancing training with family life. She's unsure whether her teaching experience counts as relevant experience. She's worried she doesn't sound academic enough compared to younger
并且经常是学生在遇到困难时会主动寻求帮助的教职员工。她完成了保障培训、教牧关怀工作，并作为其职责的一部分，定期与儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）、社会护理和教育心理学家联络。她本科获得了二等一学位，专业是英语文学，但没有正式的心理学学位。她有一些顾虑：她觉得自己重新培训太老了，担心从底层重新开始；她对财务以及平衡培训与家庭生活感到焦虑；她不确定自己的教学经验是否算作相关经验；她担心与年轻的
applicants, and she's overwhelmed by the different routes and conversion courses and assistant roles and kind of Ed Syke versus Clint Syke. She has to has got a load of strengths. So she's good at managing distress, she's got strong systems thinking, leadership, supervision of staff, she understands child development through lived and personal experience because she's a mama and she's resilient time management and she thinks she's pretty emotionally contained. All right Claire. So if we had Sarah with us, what would we be thinking about with her? Well, I mean she's got so many transferable skills. hasn't she? Just looking at the vignette myself. Safeguarding, pastoral care,
申请者相比，自己听起来不够学术，而且被不同的途径、转换课程、助理职位以及教育心理学与临床心理学的区别搞得不知所措。但她有很多优势：她擅长管理压力，具备很强的系统思维、领导力、员工督导能力，因为她是母亲，所以通过生活和个人经验理解儿童发展，而且她有韧性、时间管理能力强，并且她认为自己情绪相当稳定。好了，Claire。如果我们有 Sarah 在场，我们会怎么想呢？嗯，我的意思是她有很多可迁移的技能，不是吗？看看这个案例：保障、教牧关怀、
liaising with CAMs, the MDT work, social care, Ed Sykes. Yeah, I mean, she's definitely got options, isn't she? And definitely not too old. That's for sure. She's definitely not too old. Yeah, I think I'd kind of want to chat with Sarah to ask, like, how important, how passionate does she feel about this goal of retraining? It's absolutely achievable, but it's really hard work. Would this be the right time for her with the ages of her children? So I know they're seven and ten. I have, I'm working with trainees that have younger children and they're managing. and they're doing they're amazing they're like super mums and super dads it's i'd want to know yeah how
与 CAMHS 联络、多学科团队（MDT）工作、社会护理、教育心理学家。是的，我的意思是她肯定有选择，对吧？而且绝对没有太老。这一点是肯定的。她绝对没有太老。是的，我想我会想和 Sarah 聊聊，问问她对这个重新培训的目标有多大的热情？这绝对是可以实现的，但非常辛苦。考虑到她孩子的年龄，现在是合适的时机吗？我知道他们分别是 7 岁和 10 岁。我正在与有更小孩子的实习生合作，他们都能应付得过来。他们做得非常棒，他们是超级妈妈和超级爸爸。我想知道，是的，她有多
much does she want this yeah it's a very it's a very good point you know you do need to really want this and it it almost sounds like maybe she's thinking i need a change um um uh and i don't yeah maybe it is maybe it is like she really wants this she's worked with she's worked with the clinicians and she feels like this is this is her now but um it isn't easy i guess if she wanted to explore her options, then maybe a psychology undergraduate degree is going to serve her well anyway because it will help her to kind of solidify her thinking, to put theory, you know, maybe not into practice now, but to kind of get it slotted up into her head ready for when and if she does do something. And maybe doing that with maybe somewhere
渴望实现这个目标？这是一个非常好的观点。你确实需要非常渴望这一点，听起来她可能在想“我需要改变”，也许她真的很想要这个。她与临床医生共事过，觉得这就是她现在的方向，但这并不容易。我想如果她想探索自己的选择，那么心理学本科学位无论如何都会对她有帮助，因为它将帮助她巩固思维，将理论——也许现在还不能付诸实践——但可以先装进脑子里，为将来可能做的事情做好准备。也许通过像
like the Open University might be a really good way for her to not have to necessarily drop work that pays her, of course, when she's got a young family to support. I know that you did a degree with the Open University, didn't you? I did. And I started that at the age of 40. And that was, for me, that was my first degree. Sarah has a degree, doesn't she? So she could probably bypass the psychology undergrad and go straight for the master's conversion. But yeah, a degree at 40 is absolutely doable. I think at the time my children were, I think 11 and 13 when I started. My daughter was definitely still at primary school.
开放大学（Open University）这样的机构来完成学业，对她来说可能是一个非常好的方式，这样她就不必一定要放弃那份能养家糊口的工作，毕竟她还要抚养年幼的孩子。我知道你是在开放大学拿的学位，对吧？是的。我是在 40 岁时开始学习的。对我来说，那是我的第一个学位。Sarah 已经有一个学位了，对吧？所以她可能可以直接跳过心理学本科，直接申请硕士转换课程。但是的，40 岁读学位绝对是可行的。我想当时我开始学习时，我的孩子们大概 11 岁和 13 岁。我女儿当时肯定还在上小学。
Yeah, and a degree with the Open University is really good. It gives you that flexibility. You can study at a time that suits you. So a lot of my study would be of an evening. I worked during the daytime, and I would do my study and assignments in the evening. It's really accessible Open University, especially for older students.
是的，开放大学的学位真的很好。它给了你灵活性。你可以在适合你的时间学习。所以我大部分的学习都是在晚上进行的。我白天工作，晚上做学习和作业。开放大学真的非常容易获取，特别是对于大龄学生来说。
and students with other commitments like family children and other jobs as well. Yeah, I wrote the case study and I already forgot that she has a degree already. So yeah, she might well be able to do a two-year master's conversion. Do you know whether some employers are happy for people to take a bit of study leave, to kind of work in their employed time? Or are you like, I've got no idea, Marianne. I've got no clue. I don't know. The answer is I don't know. However, as a teacher, obviously, term time is teachers work so incredibly hard, don't they? And some of my closest friends have been teachers. They've since left the profession, just as Sarah is thinking of doing so as well. But I suppose the upside is the school holidays.
以及有家庭、孩子和其他工作等其他负担的学生。是的，我写了这个案例研究，却忘了她已经有一个学位了。所以是的，她很可能可以读一个两年的硕士转换课程。你知道有些雇主是否乐意让员工休一点学习假，在工作时间进行学习吗？还是说你也不知道，Marianne？我一点头绪都没有。我不知道。答案是我不知道。然而，作为一名教师，显然学期期间教师工作非常辛苦，不是吗？我的一些密友就是老师。她们后来离开了这个行业，就像 Sarah 现在考虑做的那样。但我想好处是学校假期。
And they would probably be a really good opportunity for Sarah. She's going to have to balance obviously childcare as well with the children in the school holidays. But she'd have maybe more capacity and energy mentally within the school holiday periods. Although I know as mum's, they're also our super busy periods as well, aren't they? Yeah. And I do find, I'm obviously self-employed now. So I've got the luxury that I can kind of control my own diary. I do find that I need at least a week off when the kids break as well. And I'm not even working in a school.
那对 Sarah 来说可能是一个非常好的机会。当然，她必须在学校假期里平衡育儿问题。但在学校假期期间，她的心理容量和精力可能会更多。虽然我知道作为妈妈，那也是我们超级忙碌的时期，不是吗？是的。我确实发现，我现在是自雇人士。所以我很奢侈，可以控制自己的日程。我确实发现当孩子们放假时，我至少需要休息一周。即使我不在学校工作。
Like I genuinely need that time to down my tools and to just, you know, parent or just, you know, just work without seeing clients. So I might do bits and pieces on my laptop. But I do really need that time as a parent. And I think there's a reason why the schools are organized in the way they are to give us kind of breaks every six weeks. it's because I think as humans we respond really well to that. It's a lot. It's a lot. And for Sarah, yeah, the ages of her children, seven and ten. It's a lot, but she's, you know, it probably is an ideal time for her. Her children are a little bit older. So if she was to do the two years, master's conversion, and she could do that part-time,
我真的需要那段时间放下工作，只是去当个家长，或者只是在不看客户的情况下工作。所以我可能会在笔记本电脑上做一点零碎的事情。但我作为家长确实非常需要那段时间。我认为学校以这种方式组织是有原因的，每六周给我们放一次假。因为我认为作为人类，我们对这种节奏反应很好。这确实很多。对于 Sarah 来说，她孩子的年龄是 7 岁和 10 岁。这确实很多，但她可能正处于一个理想的时间。她的孩子稍微大了一点。所以如果她要读两年的硕士转换课程，并且可以兼职完成，
alongside her teaching and being a mom and a parent. That would also give her a bit of breathing space as well before she looks at going down the clinical psychology pathway or whether that's the educational psychologist pathway. It would give a little bit of breathing space, I suppose, and the children would be a little bit older. But I still advocate, you know, it is possible. And like I say, I have trainees with,
同时兼顾教学、当妈妈和家长。这也会在她考虑走临床心理学道路还是教育心理学道路之前，给她一点喘息的空间。我想这会给她一点喘息的空间，而且孩子们也会稍微大一点。但我仍然主张，你知道，这是可能的。就像我说的，我的同届实习生中有带着年幼孩子的，他们做得非常出色。
in my cohort that have children, younger children, and they're smashing it. Yeah, I think they need you in a different way at that stage as well, don't they? So my eldest is quite, you know, confident and capable to kind of occupy himself a little bit more than when they're very young, you know, you can't do that. You'd struggle to kind of write an essay at your kitchen table whilst they were watching see BBs or whatever. I think when they get a little bit older, they might want to spend a bit more time by themselves anyway. Not, you know, all children are different. Of course they are. But there might be, I think for me, around that age.
是的，我觉得他们在那个阶段以不同的方式需要你，对吧？所以我的大孩子相当自信且有能力，比他们很小的时候更能自己玩一会儿，你知道，你不能那样做。当他们在看儿童节目时，你很难在餐桌上写论文。我觉得当他们大一点的时候，他们可能无论如何都想多花点时间自己待着。当然，每个孩子都不同。但我想对我来说，大约那个年龄。
So when I left the NHS, when was that? 2021. Yeah, my children were probably around that age, is what I would say. near my eldest one was around that age. And I just had this sense of, oh, okay, like a bit more liberation. Like I don't need to be everything to these children anymore. Like even that they get invited to play dates and stuff and they want to hang out with their friends. And, you know, they're not just looking to me to be everything for them. And so that allowed me to carve out different niches in my own life. And I think to do that joy audit that's really important to think about what do I enjoy,
所以当我离开英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）时，那是什么时候？2021 年。是的，我会说我的孩子们当时大概就是那个年纪。我当时有一种感觉，哦，好的，有一点解放感。就像我不再需要成为这些孩子的一切。甚至他们会被邀请去参加游戏约会，他们想和朋友们出去玩。而且，他们不再仅仅指望我成为他们的一切。所以这让我能够在自己的生活中开辟出不同的空间。我认为进行那种“快乐审计”（joy audit）非常重要，去思考我喜欢什么，
what ignites me, what do I not like doing, which will be an MDT meeting, that is a way to kill Marianne, you know, and to do more of what I like and less of what I, what I don't. So with Sarah then, would we be saying that she just focus on the education for now rather than adding in any kind of additional experience type stuff for now? I think so. I think she has a lot of responsibility already in her job. And like I say, she has an abundance of really transferable skills into psychology.
什么能点燃我的热情，我不喜欢做什么——比如多学科团队会议，那简直是 Marianne 的杀手，你知道——然后多做我喜欢的，少做我不喜欢的。那么对于 Sarah，我们会建议她现在只专注于教育，而不是增加任何额外的经验类工作吗？我想是的。我觉得她在工作中已经承担了很多责任。就像我说的，她拥有大量可以迁移到心理学领域的技能。
You know, I would, for me personally, I would say to Sarah, okay, get your masters, do your master's conversion course that will give you the accreditation. that you need to apply for the doctorate and just focus on that for now. I think trying to gain other clinical experience, I think that would be too much. She works all time. She's a teacher in a secondary school. I mean, I think teachers are absolutely amazing. Patients of saints.
你知道，对我个人而言，我会对 Sarah 说，好的，拿到你的硕士学位，完成你的硕士转换课程，那将为你提供申请博士学位所需的认证，现在只专注于那个就好。我觉得试图获得其他临床经验，那会太多了。她全职工作。她是一名中学老师。我的意思是，我觉得老师们真的太了不起了。简直是圣人。
Yeah. And I think it's just different. So the children of this current generation are just different to teach and different to try and, I don't know, tow the line. As a teacher, you need to be able to kind of, you know, get the pack to behave themselves generally, don't you? And I think that's just from my experiences of listening to stories from my eldest son's secondary. that's becoming harder and harder. So Sarah is probably exhausted. I'm not surprised she's thinking it's tricky.
是的。而且我觉得这只是不同。这一代的孩子在教学上就是不同，试图去——我不知道——遵守纪律也不同。作为一名老师，你需要能够让这群孩子总体上表现得体，对吧？而这只是根据我听到的我大儿子中学的故事，这变得越来越难了。所以 Sarah 可能精疲力竭了。我不奇怪她觉得这很棘手。
And they're not just teachers anymore, are they? Teacher friends of mine have said, you know, we're not just there to teach. We're there in a safeguarding capacity. We're there as social workers. We're there as therapists. You know, they have, they wear so many hats. and are so experience and would, you know, it would be a great loss to education for Sarah to leave,
而且他们不再仅仅是老师了，对吧？我的老师朋友们说，我们不仅仅是为了教书。我们还承担着保障职责。我们是社会工作者。我们是治疗师。你知道，他们戴着这么多顶帽子，而且经验丰富，如果 Sarah 离开教育界，那将是一个巨大的损失，
but their loss would be our gain because we could have Sarah come and work with us. We certainly need more Sarah's coming into the profession. Yeah, so do your masters, check that you actually really do like it. You know, you might discover that actually you really love the research stuff and you might go into research. Or you might decide that actually you'd want to be, you know, a clinical associate psychologist or, you know, a PWP. And that might light you up. But do the Masters and I think just see what you think. See what you think to studying again as well.
但他们的损失将是我们的收获，因为我们可以让 Sarah 来和我们一起工作。我们确实需要更多像 Sarah 这样的人进入这个行业。是的，所以去读硕士吧，检查一下你是否真的喜欢它。你知道，你可能会发现其实你真的很喜欢研究方面的东西，你可能会从事研究。或者你可能会决定其实你想成为一名临床助理心理学家，或者心理健康从业者（PWP）。那可能会点燃你的热情。但去读硕士吧，我想看看你的想法。看看你对再次学习有什么想法。
Because, of course, that will have been some time ago. And when you are studying, do reach out for your student support service and your Centre for Academic Writing and all of that stuff to help you because, you know, you are in essence paying their wages as well. They're a service that you should use and shouldn't feel any stigma about using. So, yeah, I mean, I would, I highly recommend the Open University. They do do the master's conversion course. also know that Brunel do offer the course, Brunel University offer the course remotely as well. So I would recommend 100% that she looks into this and really considers. But that return to education and studying will also help to inform her whether this is the right path for her. It certainly was for me.
因为，当然，那已经是很久以前的事了。当你学习时，一定要寻求学生支持服务、学术写作中心以及所有这些资源来帮助你，因为，你知道，本质上你也在支付他们的工资。他们是你应该使用的服务，不应该对使用它们感到任何羞耻。所以，是的，我的意思是，我强烈推荐开放大学。他们确实有硕士转换课程。我也知道布鲁内尔大学（Brunel University）也远程提供该课程。所以我 100% 建议她研究一下这个，并认真考虑。但重返教育和学习也将有助于她判断这是否是适合她的道路。对我来说确实如此。
I started studying and I don't ever want to stop. My body's telling me to stop, but my brain just. wants to keep going. So yeah I think I think go for it. Amazing. Okay so we've got a green light to proceed to the next stage which for Sarah looks like it might involve the masters. Do you want to guide us through the next vignette Claire? Absolutely. Okay so case study number two we have Mark he's a 35 year old male an NHS office manager so he works in a community mental health service. He manages rotors referrals, waiting lists and service data. He works closely with psychologists, nurses, psychiatrists and support workers but
我开始学习后，就再也不想停下来了。我的身体在告诉我停下来，但我的大脑只是想继续前进。所以是的，我觉得去尝试吧。太棒了。好的，我们已经获得了进入下一阶段的绿灯，对于 Sarah 来说，这看起来可能涉及硕士学位。Claire，你想引导我们进入下一个案例吗？当然。好的，案例研究二，我们有 Mark，他是一名 35 岁的男性，是 NHS 的办公室经理，他在社区心理健康服务部门工作。他管理排班、转诊、候补名单和服务数据。他与心理学家、护士、精神科医生和支持人员密切合作，但
does not currently have a clinical role. He has a Bachelor of Science in Psychology, achieving a 2-2 and he completed that 12 years ago. At the time, he lacked confidence and direction and didn't apply for assistant psychologist roles. He moved into admin for financial stability and he's stayed there ever since. He's single, lives alone and works full time. So his current concerns are Mark feels stuck and worries that he has wasted time. He believes his admin role isn't good enough for applications. He lacks confidence speaking about himself and his skills. He feels behind his peers who qualified years ago and worries about being a man in a predominantly female profession. He struggles with imposter syndrome and comparison. So his strengths are excellent understanding of
目前没有临床角色。他拥有心理学理学学士学位，成绩是二等二，那是 12 年前完成的。当时，他缺乏信心和方向，没有申请助理心理学家职位。为了财务稳定，他转行做了行政，并一直待在那里。他单身，独居，全职工作。所以他目前的顾虑是：Mark 感到被困住了，担心自己浪费了时间。他认为自己的行政角色在申请时不够好。他缺乏谈论自己和技能的信心。他觉得自己落后于几年前获得资格的同龄人，并担心作为一名男性在女性占主导地位的行业中工作。他与冒名顶替综合症和比较心理作斗争。所以他的优势是：对 NHS 系统、路径和压力有极好的理解，
NHS systems, pathways and pressures, regular exposure to clinical decision-making, risk management and service delivery, strong organizational communication and leadership skills. He's trusted by clinicians and often acts as an informal bridge between teams and he remains calm under pressure and is used to holding complexity. So what he wants, Mark wants to become a clinical psychologist but feels unclear on whether he should apply for AP roles or further study, how to make his current role more relevant, how to talk reflectively rather than descriptively, and whether he is competitive enough he wants a practical plan rather than vague encouragement
经常接触临床决策、风险管理和服务交付，具备很强的组织沟通和领导能力。他受到临床医生的信任，经常充当团队之间的非正式桥梁，并且在压力下保持冷静，习惯于处理复杂性。所以他想要的是：Mark 想成为一名临床心理学家，但不清楚是应该申请助理心理学家（AP）职位还是继续深造，如何让目前的角色更具相关性，如何进行反思性而非描述性的交流，以及他是否具有足够的竞争力。他想要一个切实可行的计划，而不是模糊的鼓励。
okay then mark um thank you um and what i would say is you sound like you're amazing at your job um you know admin are the backbone of of kind of mental health services so don't underestimate what you're doing and how much people do value you and you know you're probably that person that in the office people are like, I don't know, ask Mark. Mark will know. Mark will know. Mark will definitely know because he's dependable and reliable. So don't underestimate you and what you're doing. The only reservation I've got is the tutu. And obviously, you know, I came pretty close to a two to myself. There's a lot of reasons why that might have been around for Mark. If you were to apply to the doctorate in clinical
好的，Mark，谢谢你。我想说的是，听起来你在工作中非常出色。你知道，行政人员是心理健康服务的支柱，所以不要低估你所做的事情以及人们对你的重视程度。而且，你知道，你可能就是办公室里那种人们会说“我不知道，去问 Mark，Mark 会知道”的人。Mark 一定会知道，因为他可靠且值得信赖。所以不要低估你自己和你所做的事情。我唯一的保留意见是那个二等二学位。显然，你知道，我自己也差点拿到二等二。对于 Mark 来说，这背后有很多原因。如果你要通过清算所（Clearinghouse）申请临床心理学博士学位，
psychology via the clearinghouse, lots of courses will not accept 2-2 unless you've got evidence that kind of strengthened you academically. So what I would say is looking into a master's to evidence that Mark is kind of strong in that would be kinder. Because you know, you could carry on applying year after year to the doctorate in clinical psychology and then not get shortlisted and it might be because you're just being screened out at that very early stage. And really we do want you to feel like you do have strengths in academia, that that's not scaring you off because it's so much a part of what we're doing. You know, you were in your first year currently,
很多课程不会接受二等二学位，除非你有证据证明你在学术上有所加强。所以我想说的是，考虑读一个硕士学位来证明 Mark 在学术上很强会更好。因为，你知道，你可能会年复一年地申请临床心理学博士学位，然后没有进入面试名单，这可能是因为你在非常早期的阶段就被筛选掉了。我们确实希望你觉得自己在学术上有优势，不要因为这部分是我们工作的重要组成部分而感到害怕。你知道，你目前在第一年，
and you said you've already had to put in your research proposal for your dissertation, for your thesis, sorry. So it is part of what we do, and we're aiming to be scientists, practitioners, that conduct research and weave it into our practice. Have you got any thoughts on Mark Clare? Yeah, so having already completed the psychology degree, obviously unlike Sarah, he already has that insight into psychology and the profession and the subject matter around psychology.
你说你已经提交了论文的研究计划。所以这是我们工作的一部分，我们的目标是成为科学家、实践者，进行研究并将其融入我们的实践中。Claire，你对 Mark 有什么想法吗？是的，既然已经完成了心理学学位，显然与 Sarah 不同，他已经对心理学、这个行业以及心理学相关的学科有了深入了解。
He sounds really motivated to qualify in as a clinical psychologist. Obviously, it expresses how his... his peers around him. He feels that they've kind of overtaken him and they've gone on to qualify. He's in a great situation. The two, two doesn't need to be a barrier. Like you said, Marianne, he can go ahead and he can complete his master's conversion, come out with a really good grade. But yes, you are right with the declin process, clearing house. I think all the vast majority are looking for high two ones to get onto their particular DECLIN program. But he can go and do a master's, lots of transferable skills yet again.
他听起来非常有动力去获得临床心理学家的资格。显然，他表达了周围的同龄人似乎已经超越了他，并获得了资格。他处于一个很好的境地。二等二学位不需要成为障碍。就像你说的，Marianne，他可以继续完成他的硕士转换课程，并以非常好的成绩毕业。但是的，关于清算所的流程，你是对的。我想绝大多数项目都在寻找高二等一学位来进入他们的临床博士项目。但他可以去读硕士，再次拥有很多可迁移的技能。
I'd probably be interested in seeing, like in terms of the AP assistant psychologist roles, is that something that he's looking to go on to once he has his masters? What do you think? Because he could pursue that now and do his, do his masters at the same time. So, yeah, he could. Because when you're applying for an assistant psychologist role, you are often competing with somebody that's maybe already worked in relevant experience roles for many years or a couple of years. And maybe they've, maybe they've graduated a while ago or they've already got something under their belt. So Mark's already got those some things now.
我可能感兴趣的是，就助理心理学家（AP）职位而言，这是他拿到硕士学位后想要从事的方向吗？你觉得呢？因为他现在就可以追求这个，同时完成他的硕士学位。所以，是的，他可以。因为当你申请助理心理学家职位时，你通常是在与那些可能已经在相关经验岗位上工作多年或一两年的人竞争。也许他们毕业有一段时间了，或者他们已经有了一些经验。所以 Mark 现在已经有了一些这样的东西。
He could probably, if we could, you know, I think some time in the aspiring psychologist membership might not be a bad thing. Like we could help raise his confidence and help him practice, you know, skills and talking about himself and talking reflectively. But yeah, so you raise a valid point. Like he could do the masters, but he could be doing some other relevant experience roles at the same time. And depending on what level he's at, you know, I used to work with administrators that were kind of level, band three, band four, band five, band six. He might already be kind of at a similar pay level to AP as well. So he might be able to kind of move with less pain financially.
如果可以的话，我想在“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）中花点时间对他来说可能不是坏事。我们可以帮助提升他的自信心，帮助他练习谈论自己和进行反思性交流的技能。但是的，你提出了一个有效的观点。他可以读硕士，但同时也可以做一些其他相关经验的工作。而且根据他的级别，你知道，我过去和行政人员一起工作，他们是三级、四级、五级、六级。他可能已经处于与 AP 类似的薪资水平了。所以他可能可以在财务上以较小的痛苦进行转换。
Also, I don't want Mark to feel like because he's got a two-two, that it's punitive, like he's got to do a master's. Because actually lots of applicants who already have a two-one, sometimes even a first, will also do a master's, because that helps to strengthen them. So this isn't a, oh, I've got to. It's like a, I get to. But also that's going to really help me
另外，我不希望 Mark 因为他有二等二学位就觉得这是一种惩罚，好像他必须读硕士。因为实际上，许多已经拥有二等一学位，有时甚至是二等一以上学位的申请者也会读硕士，因为这有助于加强他们的背景。所以这不是一个“我必须”，而是一个“我可以”。但这也会真正帮助我
to optimally show myself as being capable and competent. And to get your hand in a bit more because you haven't studied for a while. And so to be fresh and to have, I think a fresh academic reference can be really great as well. So what I would say for anyone that's undertaking a master's or even an undergrad is make very good friends, you know, with your academic supervisor so that they do know you. So maybe not friends. That might be a bit strong.
以最佳方式展示自己的能力和胜任力。而且让你重新上手，因为你已经有一段时间没学习了。所以拥有一份新鲜的学术推荐信也非常棒。所以我想对任何正在攻读硕士甚至本科的人说，一定要和你的学术导师成为好朋友，你知道，这样他们才了解你。所以也许不是朋友，那可能有点过头了。
But make sure you're going for meetings. Make sure that they genuinely do know about you and your work and your research. So that when you ask them, you know, to write you a reference next year, the year of. after the year after that. They're like, oh, Mark, yeah, I remember Mark. Otherwise it can be really tricky, aren't it, Claire? Yeah, absolutely.
但确保你去参加会议。确保他们真正了解你、你的工作和你的研究。这样当你明年或后年请他们为你写推荐信时，他们会说：“哦，Mark，是的，我记得 Mark。”否则这会非常棘手，对吧，Claire？是的，绝对是。
I stayed in contact with my final year undergrad tutor. I'd heard that the university, for example, like a lot of the universities, will provide a very generic reference suitability statement for the D-Clean. So I was quite quite, strategic actually I kind of kept in contact he was a great tutor absolutely
我和我的本科最后一年导师保持了联系。我听说大学，例如，很多大学会为临床博士申请提供非常通用的推荐信适用性声明。所以我当时相当有策略，我保持了联系，他是一位很棒的导师，绝对
great Alberto was his name who's wonderful and I I stayed in contact so when it came to that suitability statement for the Declin application I was able to put in his email address he's his open university direct email address because I have heard from others that their universities where they did their undergrad or they did their masters, provide these very generic references, suitability statements. So, yeah, a little trick, yeah, stay in contact with them. And get their email, get their actual email rather than the generic admin one, so it's more likely to end up in the right place.
很棒，他叫 Alberto，非常出色。我保持了联系，所以当涉及到临床博士申请的适用性声明时，我能够填入他的电子邮件地址，他开放大学的直接电子邮件地址，因为我从其他人那里听说，他们读本科或硕士的大学提供的推荐信和适用性声明非常通用。所以，是的，一个小技巧，保持联系。并获取他们的电子邮件，获取他们真实的电子邮件，而不是通用的行政邮箱，这样更有可能到达正确的地方。
Yeah, brilliant advice. So, you know, he could stay where he is and do his masters. he could move on and apply for AP roles, or maybe he could be thinking about, well, could I join, you know, an NHS bank service and maybe do, you know, a shift a week in a clinical setting? So perhaps as a support worker, an HCA, that kind of thing, on like an inpatient ward or kind of something like that.
是的，绝妙的建议。所以，你知道，他可以留在原地读硕士，他可以继续前进申请 AP 职位，或者也许他可以考虑，我能加入 NHS 的银行服务（bank service），也许在临床环境中每周做一个班次吗？比如作为支持人员、医疗保健助理（HCA），在住院病房或类似的地方。
Maybe he could, you know, depending on his time and his inclination, he could go and do some work doing home caring or, you know, caring work in a home, something to give him experience of the clinical populations that clinical psychologists would work with, which would be people with intellectual disabilities, children, young people and families, adult mental health, older adults, broadly speaking, other other areas are, of course, available, but generically, that's the areas that we look at. So what does he enjoy? What could he do that might be a paid opportunity. And I don't love advocating for unpaid work, but, you know, lots of people do volunteer with services like Shout and the Samaritans and stuff like that.
也许他可以，根据他的时间和意愿，去做一些家庭护理工作，或者在养老院做护理工作，做一些能让他获得临床心理学家会接触到的临床人群经验的事情，比如智力障碍人士、儿童、年轻人和家庭、成人心理健康、老年人，广义上来说，当然还有其他领域，但通常来说，这就是我们关注的领域。所以他喜欢什么？他能做什么可能是有偿的机会？我不喜欢提倡无偿工作，但你知道，很多人确实在像 Shout 和撒玛利亚会（Samaritans）这样的服务机构做志愿者。
So that it's giving your time in a way that is not taking up loads of it, but you're also getting access to that work that helps your skills and confidence to grow. Yeah, absolutely. He's definitely got. options. I think if it's not a pay cut for him to apply for assistant psychologist roles would be a really smart move actually. And I think he'd be a really good candidate. Securing your first AP role can be really difficult and we hear that it can take some people months and months and months to get that interview and to secure that first post. But work working within the NHS and having an understanding of NHS system, saying clinical work,
所以这是一种不占用大量时间但又能让你获得有助于提升技能和信心的工作经验的方式。是的，绝对。他肯定有选择。如果申请助理心理学家职位对他来说不是降薪，那实际上是一个非常明智的举动。而且我觉得他会是一个非常好的候选人。获得第一个 AP 职位可能非常困难，我们听说有些人可能需要几个月甚至更久才能获得面试机会并获得第一个职位。但在 NHS 内部工作并了解 NHS 系统，进行临床工作，
albeit he's not working clinically directly himself. He does have that understanding of how that looks and how that works. And I think it put him in a really strong position actually to apply for AP roles. And AP roles are not the gold standard, contrary to belief. They are not the gold standard for the Declin applications. They are just one route and that's one route that he can access off the back of his degree that he currently has. He can and I've just had another idea Claire so depending on where he lives in the country or in the UK he also could apply for clinical associate psychologist training which actually is a master's and is paid. Now the difficulty with that, it's not really difficulty, but the barrier to that is that once you qualify,
尽管他自己没有直接进行临床工作。他确实了解那看起来是什么样子，运作方式如何。而且我认为这实际上让他处于申请 AP 职位的非常有利的位置。而且 AP 职位并不是金标准，与人们的看法相反。它们不是临床博士申请的金标准。它们只是一个途径，那是他可以利用他目前拥有的学位进入的一个途径。他可以，而且我刚才又想到了一个主意，Claire，所以根据他住在英国的哪个地方，他也可以申请临床助理心理学家（CAP）培训，这实际上是一个硕士学位，而且是有薪水的。现在困难在于，这并不是真正的困难，但障碍在于一旦你获得资格，
if you've had kind of a funding to do that, which you would be because you're paid, you then have to have at least two years passed before you can then go on and have additional funding to do your doctorate. But we would hope that he would really like being a clinical associate psychologist and would want to do that for a few years. You know, if he hated it, it might be a sign actually I don't want to go on and become a clinical psychologist, but also once you've had that funding, and the same for like psychological well-being practitioner, if you've had the funding to do that,
如果你获得了资助来做这件事，因为你是带薪的，那么你必须至少过去两年，然后才能获得额外的资助去读博士。但我们希望他会真的很喜欢成为一名临床助理心理学家，并愿意做几年。你知道，如果他讨厌它，那可能是一个信号，说明我不想继续成为一名临床心理学家，但一旦你获得了资助，对于像心理健康从业者（PWP）这样的职位也是一样，如果你获得了资助，
you don't necessarily have to do that job afterwards. You just can't have more funding straight away. So if you wanted to go on from your PWP course and then go on and become an assistant psychologist, then you could, but you couldn't have any additional funding whilst you're waiting. So, yeah, depending on where he lives and whether they're doing intakes for that, a trainee cap role might work really well for him.
你并不一定非要在之后做那份工作。你只是不能马上获得更多资助。所以如果你想从你的 PWP 课程继续前进，然后成为一名助理心理学家，那么你可以，但你在等待期间不能获得任何额外资助。所以，是的，根据他住在哪里以及他们是否在进行招生，实习 CAP 角色可能对他非常有效。
Yeah, it's a really good option. They paid at band five, then they get paid at band six when they qualify. Yeah, clinical associate psychologist, also known as caps. I have a couple within my cohort who were caps and the cap pathway. obviously waited the two years before applying for the declin. It's set them up really well, put them in a really strong position for the declin application process. I think that's a really good option. I think I'm telling Mark, get a cap for a mark.
是的，这是一个非常好的选择。他们按五级薪资支付，获得资格后按六级支付。是的，临床助理心理学家，也称为 CAPs。我的同届中有几个是 CAPs，CAP 途径显然在申请临床博士之前等待了两年。这让他们准备得非常好，让他们在临床博士申请过程中处于非常有利的位置。我认为这是一个非常好的选择。我想我会告诉 Mark，为 Mark 争取一个 CAP 职位。
Go on, go on, Mark. Do it. And you'll get a pay rise. You'll be banned fine. And if anyone's watching or listening to this and they're like, oh, I could be, Mark. I could be Sarah, that's a really good idea. Or what about this? We would welcome comments and questions. So people can comment on YouTube. They can do a Q&A on Spotify or harass me down on social media
加油，加油，Mark。去做吧。你会加薪的。你会达到五级。如果有人正在观看或收听这个节目，他们想，哦，我可以成为 Mark。我可以成为 Sarah，那是一个非常好的主意。或者这个怎么样？我们欢迎评论和提问。所以人们可以在 YouTube 上评论。他们可以在 Spotify 上进行问答，或者在社交媒体上骚扰我，
where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Any other thoughts or kind of takeaway points for people that are thinking, I think I want to be a psychologist. But I'm a bit older, I guess. Or even if they're, you know, they're 24 and they've graduated and they're like, I've done history. What did I do that for? Any advice?
我在那里到处都是 Marianne Trent 博士。对于那些认为“我想成为一名心理学家，但我年纪稍微大了一点”的人，或者即使他们 24 岁，刚毕业，他们说“我学的是历史，我为什么要那样做？”的人，还有其他想法或要点吗？
I know we're looking at older applicants because we want to empower them and have that sense of it not being too late. But any other parting thoughts, Claire? So, yeah, for me, anything I post about my journey in relation to my career change, transitioning into academia, in my 40s,
我知道我们关注的是大龄申请者，因为我们想赋予他们力量，让他们觉得现在还不晚。但还有其他临别赠言吗，Claire？所以，是的，对我来说，任何关于我职业生涯转变、在 40 多岁进入学术界的帖子，
I get a lot of interest and a lot of people reach out. to me a lot of people will private message me on LinkedIn and ask for advice whether in a similar situation and my advice is always very very clear and if you are motivated and you set yourself ambitious goals and it's a pathway that you want to take then go for it that there is no age limit we offer so much more as mature students, you know, we come with lived experience, older applicant trainees, we have a lot to offer. I'd also like to say with regards to that also, I have quite a young co-haul.
我都会得到很多关注，很多人会联系我。很多人会在 LinkedIn 上私信我寻求建议，无论他们是否处于类似的情况，我的建议总是非常非常明确的：如果你有动力，并且为自己设定了雄心勃勃的目标，而且这是一条你想走的道路，那就去做吧。没有年龄限制。作为成熟学生，我们提供了太多东西，你知道，我们带着生活经验而来，大龄申请者实习生，我们有很多东西可以提供。我还想说，关于这一点，我也有相当年轻的同届。
They too come with an abundance of experience, a lot of really rich lived experience and clinical experience. And I've learned so much from the younger members of my cohort. We all have something to offer and the sky's the limit as far as I'm concerned. Do I wish I'd done it sooner? Nah, I'll do it now. Because if I'd have done it sooner, I wouldn't have had my previous career. Would you start again now? So if you were retired medically now from the police force at 47, would you do it now?
他们也带来了丰富的经验，很多非常丰富的生活经验和临床经验。我从同届中年轻的成员身上学到了很多。我们每个人都有东西可以提供，在我看来，天空才是极限。我希望我早点做吗？不，我现在做。因为如果我早点做，我就不会有我之前的职业生涯了。你现在会重新开始吗？所以如果你现在 47 岁从警察部队因医疗原因退休，你会现在做吗？
Yes. Yes, I would. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, you look at retirement. Retirement age is rising, isn't it? I think for my generation, it's probably going to be probably in our 70s before we're going to be allowed to retire. But yeah, like easily, a good solid 20, 25 years. I don't ever intend to retire. I suppose it's your outlook. I'm very driven. I get a lot out of my working identity. So for me it was really important. It's not the be all and end all for everybody else, but if it's something you want and you're prepared to graft at it, then go for it. The sky's the limit. Yeah, I totally agree and I don't necessarily predict myself retiring.
是的。是的，我会的。是的，我是说，看看退休这件事。退休年龄在提高，不是吗？我想对于我们这一代人来说，可能要到70多岁才能退休。但确实，轻松地再干个20、25年是没问题的。我从没打算退休。我想这取决于你的心态。我很有动力。我从我的职业身份中获得了很多。所以对我来说这真的很重要。这对其他人来说可能不是最重要的，但如果你想要它，并且愿意为此努力，那就去追求吧。一切皆有可能。是的，我完全同意，我也不认为自己会退休。
Because if you've got, even if you've got 25 years left of work, why not make it something that you love? Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. No, no regrets. I'm wonderfully exhausted in my first year as a trainee, balancing placement and university and life, but I still feel like I've won the bloody lottery, getting a place, and it feels an absolute privilege to be walking this pathway, and you can do too. That's so wonderful. What lovely advice to leave it on, and it's always a privilege to speak with you. So thank you for sharing your wisdom, your compassion and your very wise words, Claire. Thank you Mary and lovely to see you again. And and you, take care.
因为即使你还剩下25年的工作时间，为什么不让它成为你热爱的事业呢？绝对是这样。是的。是的。是的。绝对没错。不，不后悔。作为一名实习生，我在第一年里感到非常疲惫，要在实习、大学和生活之间取得平衡，但我仍然觉得我简直中了彩票一样幸运，能获得这个名额。能走上这条道路绝对是一种荣幸，你也可以做到。太棒了。多么好的建议，能和你交谈总是一种荣幸。所以谢谢你分享你的智慧、你的同情心和你非常睿智的话语，克莱尔。谢谢你，玛丽，很高兴再次见到你。你也是，保重。
Take care. Bye now. What an absolute pleasure to speak with Claire and we had to cut the very end of our post chat short because I had to go and run and help my little boy who has migraines and he was running to the toilet to be sick and didn't even realise he was sick before then I'll have to go and help clear up the hallway and my son. So these are some of the real life challenges of parenting children. Certainly the real life experience for my nine-year-old. Have you got any experience of having migraines yourself or maybe for your children as well? Yeah, it's certainly blights our life at times, but he kind of, he is a trooper. So yeah, thanks to Claire for allowing me to dash off so soon.
保重。再见。能和克莱尔交谈真是太愉快了，我们不得不缩短了聊天后的最后一部分，因为我得赶紧去帮我患偏头痛的小儿子，他当时正跑向厕所呕吐，在那之前他甚至没意识到自己要吐了，我得去帮忙清理走廊和照顾我儿子。这些就是养育孩子时面临的一些现实生活挑战。这确实是我九岁儿子的真实生活经历。你自己或你的孩子有偏头痛的经历吗？是的，它确实有时会困扰我们的生活，但他很坚强。所以，谢谢克莱尔让我这么快就离开。
How have you found this episode? I would love to know. What's it evoked for you? What thoughts have you got? Let me know in the comments whether you are watching on YouTube or whether you're listening on Apple or Spotify or somewhere else good too. You can always come and connect with me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do tag me in your stories if you are enjoying the content. I love to hear from you. And I genuinely think if this content, resonates with you that you would really love the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. It gets wonderful reviews and we do get people places as assistant psychologists. We get people places on PWP courses. We get people interviews and place offers on the doctorate in clinical psychology schemes too. So what's not to love? dive in, give us a try for a month and if you don't like it, you know, you can swan out there. But that happens very rarely, I have to say, people do like it and they do benefit. And I genuinely believe that psychologists are not just born in the spring.
你觉得这一集怎么样？我很想知道。它引起了你什么样的共鸣？你有什么想法？无论你是在YouTube上观看，还是在Apple、Spotify或其他平台上收听，都请在评论区告诉我。你也可以随时在社交媒体上与我联系。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。如果你喜欢这些内容，请在你的故事中标记我。我很乐意听到你的反馈。我真心认为，如果这些内容能引起你的共鸣，你一定会喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，每月仅需30英镑，没有最低期限要求。它获得了极好的评价，我们确实帮助人们获得了助理心理学家的职位。我们帮助人们进入PWP课程。我们还帮助人们获得临床心理学博士项目的面试和录取机会。所以有什么理由不喜欢呢？加入进来，试用一个月，如果你不喜欢，你知道，你可以随时退出。但我必须说，这种情况很少发生，人们确实喜欢它并从中受益。我真心相信，心理学家不仅仅是在春天诞生的。
It takes a year-round approach. But that said, if you've got interviews coming up, you are welcome to dive in and you'll get access to all of the replay content from the last four years. That's right. We turned four years old in February. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
这需要全年的努力。话虽如此，如果你即将参加面试，欢迎加入，你将获得过去四年所有重播内容的访问权限。没错，我们在二月份满四岁了。我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
令我惊讶的是，通往这一目标的途径竟然有这么多，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。